by the way the comment about teachers
being underpaid i disagree partially um
teachers get a nice little summer off uh
they can do some summer school and stuff
that they volunteer to do great uh i
think 30 percent of them should be fired
to be honest with you shouldn't be
shouldn't be teachers they should go to
a different occupation there's a lot of
people that are teachers that are
miserable that are bitter that are not
happy there's no such thing as a
performance basis just stick around and
you're going to get a raise every year
for tenure that you have in place i
don't agree with that i think there's
got to be certain protected by the union
yeah and by the way even even in the
military even in the military guess what
there were guys in the army that were
there for 20 years that were still e6's
meaning
if you don't do certain correspondence
and improve you ain't getting promoted
to e7 or e8 or e9 or whatever it is
use that same thing with teachers and
give them certain criterias to be able
to become better teachers so i think 30
percent in the military they used to do
the following when they had bad
sergeants in the army where they were
just not good leaders you know what the
army would do they'd come up to you if
you're less than 15 years they didn't
want you to retire with 20 years because
they didn't want to pay you for the rest
of your life they'd come and they would
say hey man we'll give you 30 000 for
you to leave today
flat out they'd come and say we'll give
you 20. you know how many people would
take it a lot of them because army's
sitting there saying we're wasting our
time with this person that's not going
to be a leader here's 15 grand leave
here's 30 grand leave i think many of
these districts need to go to the bad
teachers and say here's 30 000 leave you
don't need to do this anymore so this
concept about everybody being afraid to
have to say all these teachers are
perfect stop it not all business people
are great the ones who are not great
should be fired and go out of business
not all these too big to fail companies
need to stick around because some of
them don't know how to handle it they
keep doing buybacks and using taxpayers
dollars to save their own assets for
making stupid mistakes let them go out
of business let another company that's a
better operator buy them same with cops
same with firefighters same with pastor
same with teachers anybody at the bottom
30 percent of what they're doing that's
not good at you ought to get fired go
figure out something you want to do and
take care of the customer so no i don't
think all teachers are the best teachers
out there doing a great job i think 30
of them should get fired anyways
i think they're sorry just they're going
but there are genuinely there are good
teachers that love what they do they
love their they should get a raise but
they should and and but they are rare to
to find so i totally
hear you i think those teachers should
be turning here's what i would do if i
ran a state okay if i ran a state okay
say one day we campaigned you become a
governor i'm your campaign manager and
i'm sitting on the back you know we're
working together right okay you know
what we would strategize with here's
what we would do
we would take
the top 20 best teachers
we'd bring them in and guess what we're
doing to them turn them into freaking
rock stars
tell me why this person is a great
teacher we'd create a florida district
youtube channel and we would turn these
teachers into heroes and put
advertisements behind them and then the
state gives that teacher a fifty
thousand dollar tax whatever bonus that
they're getting you do to twenty
teachers what's twenty teachers and
fifty thousand dollars nothing it's a
million bucks but that million bucks is
gonna get the other teachers to say [ __ ]
maybe i gotta become a better teacher
but because we're not doing the hero
making machine of the right teachers
nobody knows what the hell is a good
teacher all we know is stick around bro
you're gonna get your 10-year [ __ ]
raisin nobody cares if you're good or
bad don't do that just makes you okay
here and we're gonna be all right i
don't agree with that i think i think
the hero making machine needs to change
but the sensitivities of parents with
kids
is a real issue and this is an area
where i would feel very uncomfortable if
you're
if your kid came and talked to me
and said something to me
and said hey uncle patrick man i'm going
to talk about something i don't feel
like i can talk my dad about it he's 16.
you know who's the first phone call i'm
making
you're calling the parent i'm calling
you bro i'm just adam can i talk to you
hey i want to tell you something bro
just remember him and i got a very good
relationship and i i look at your son
like my own son man someone tell you
this but can you handle can you promise
me that we're going to keep because i
want to help as much as i can yeah he's
struggling with this and i think you
need to know this because the last thing
i want to do and by the way if i don't
tell you
and god forbid something happens to your
son for the rest of my life i will feel
guilty about not having told you that
because no one cares more about that kid
than the parent nobody not the teacher
not the friend not the uncle not anybody
no one cares more about that kid than
the parent so i feel that part that tom
brought up this i don't know i don't
even know how to help we went into this
conversation because we have a whole
other topic to get into this was not
even on our list of topics today so now
we only have hours and 16 minutes left
with the real topics what he got up here
washington state now appears to allow
minors to undergo life-changing gender
reassignment surgery without parental
consent
under new life health insurance must
cover a gender affirming care um
including surgical treatments that were
previously denied coverage this is
january 12 20.
this is the logical next step though
when you cut out the parent well hang on
how far are they willing right this is
the logical next step when the guidance
counselor doesn't talk to the parent and
the child changes their mind and decides
that they are now she her pronouns from
he him so they've got this in their mind
what's the logical next step to fulfill
the she her pronoun right so what do
they do they go see their doctor and and
on your point you said that the guidance
counselor is a trained expert well so
are these doctors these doctors are
trained experts there's only one area we
have an issue with though here tyler
i don't disagree with them i just have
one issue guess what the issue is
there's only one issue we are debating
here telling the parent telling the
parent well i know i don't this is the
only issue so meaning he's right that
conversation is gonna be had
they're gonna have that like if i want
to join the military i'd go to miss
sinclair and i was in the sinclair i
want to join the army but i don't think
my mom's gonna support it what do you
think
do you understand like okay
my mom should probably know that no i
and i agree i'm just saying this is
you're now cutting out the parent
totally so again i i don't disagree at
all that sure they'll have the the
conversation with the guidance counselor
but first of all the guidance counselor
isn't a therapist they're not a a
non-partisan neutral actor they're gonna
have they're gonna guide the child and
if they don't tell the parent you're now
having laws where the doctors no longer
have to tell their parents i'll give you
guys the final thoughts i'll give the
two of you guys each final thoughts and
then we'll move on to topic if you have
one i have one thing to say go ahead
just so i don't want to be
we're i don't want to the issue is being
conflated and i just want to be very
clear here sure there needs to be
certain trigger points okay hey i'm
having a conversa i don't know if i'm
gay i don't know i don't know i don't
know if i like this girl
totally normal conversation if i think
i'm i'm a boy and i think about becoming
a girl if i'm thinking about committing
suicide
[ __ ] yeah inform the parents there's
trigger points that is something
completely different from hey i'm having
a normal issue those are two totally
separate things what percentage of kids
are considering changing their sex or
committing suicide the one percent well
that person those need to be waiting but
that percentage is increasing
then yes in those cases inform the
parents if it's a casual conversation in
that regard and they don't want to
inform the parents i'm okay with that i
want to be super clear on that quick
point you made a really great point
about results driven in teachers my mom
is a guidance counselor kindergarten
teacher and all whatever became a
guidance counselor she would have 30
kids lined up at her door just waiting
to see her because they loved her so
much yet the other teachers and the
other guidance counselors barely had the
same kids they were working all the same
hours my mom would work late because she
wanted to to talk with each student
individually but yet because of the
school system and because it's not run
like a business they were still paid the
same she deserves a raise their
performance met performance didn't
matter and and you bring up a really
good point there and i think that's
something that actually governors should
consider 20 20 great teachers every
quarter give them 50 000 bonus every
quarter that's 4 million a year i would
do it if i was a governor 20 teachers
every quarter need to get a 50 000
bonus given to them a state can afford
to do that go ahead tom
yeah so i want to end with facts on the
suicide side and
this is horrifying uh the trevor project
that works with johns hopkins to conduct
research studies
lgbtq youth are four times as lucky to
commit suicide than their peers
1.8 million of them communicate their
desire to commit suicide each year there
is one suicide attempt
from age 13 to 18
lgbtq youth every 45 seconds
and 45 of the lgbtq
publicly identified youth have seriously
considered suicide in the past year
i mean you call it stigmas you call it
bullying there's a lot of bad things
that happen there but you're talking
about a mental health crisis that we
need a team working on and we need
parents working on it and we need
guidance counselors not being isolated
for political reasons and we need
teachers not being isolated for
political reasons because we have a
crisis with our youth and if bill maher
is correct that the percentages are
increasing this is horrifying stat so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]